it is so wonderful to see you ben and
melissa because i just want to say thank
you for always bringing the laughter
because when you guys come together you
just bring so much joy so thank you
and we did it we did it thank you for
that and we did it with a heavy scoop of
uh canadians this time yeah yeah i love
it
yeah it's like it's so good and again
your character clark you know his
admiration for melissa's character
watching from afar just falling in love
with her you know and figuring out how
to ask her out on a date so i want to
know ben
how did you lock in melissa what was
your pickup line do you remember that
moment
when you asked melissa out
i wish it was with a pickup one like did
you hurt yourself when you fell out of
heaven
i'm not sure that's exactly the
thing like did you bump your head oh
yeah i just went right to like are you
hurt did you break your knees
oops
you want to go have dinner yeah it was
probably
we were friends for a long time first
and
we had already we met at uh groundlings
like and we were writing you know
sketches and stuff together so we had
already told each other countless
terrible lies we'd already
i think the the the big trick was that
we had already seen each other
in just
there's a code of honor i think with
sketch groups that like the worst the
the worse you can look in an outfit is
kind of like oh well they won
so he'd already seen me in like tight
curly perms and ill-fitting doctors and
after if you've seen that and you're
still if you still want to dip a toe in
that i'm like all right i've got them
from
[Music]
love at first sight right
exactly
and why is it that satan is always so
hot leslie in a catsuit
what is it what's the reason behind that
well
she uh
there there was a part in there where
she she symbolizes you know sort of uh
desire all these different things um and
also she i think she wanted to wear that
suit didn't she yeah and i was like but
i think if you were satan why would
you'd be like i look good yeah yeah
really good like you're gonna be a total
narcissist
you're not you're not going to look like
joey and you know like you had a a rough
couple of years you're going to look
like bib i was like if i was satan i'd
want to look like bib yeah satan looks
pretty amazing and your girls are the
same age as my girls which i find so
fascinating 12 and 15. uh are they into
this world do they like what you do are
they inspired
i think they you know i think all of our
humor is are
somewhat in the same realm like they
like they like the you know when things
go a little weird
they like they like that so yeah i'm not
sure if they'll get into it themselves
or not but they certainly could
so it's like they've got
something weirdly i don't think though
which i know this doesn't make any sense
i feel like they're not gonna watch us
dating which is odd because we are their
parents but they're not gonna they're
not gonna like if if we smooch on tv
they're like ew
you